Here's my answer, so I took all the i, j, w pairs from the horizontal plays
and just reassembled them with the i, j, putting in the indication that
they're going in the across direction and keeping the same word.
Then I do the same thing for the vertical plays. They came out in the j, i order.
I reassembled them back in the proper i, j order
with an indication that we are going in the down direction.
And then I took these two sets and just unioned them together.
Now, I need some definition for across and down. I can do it this way.
I could have just used strings or any unique value that could use a string across and down,
but I'm going to say that across is equal to incrementing one at a time in the i direction
and zero in the j direction.
Down is incrementing zero in the i direction and one in the j direction.